you know the thing to do was train hard
party hard
you know i mean
isn't happy hour anytime
i chase girls i drank alcohol spent
lavishly from the outside looking in
um
i was the picture of success
uh sunny williams out of australia the
only thing in this life is certain is
that
i'm the hit list by some guy uh jake
paul brother logan paul
their god yes okay
you know
uh in islam
the beauty of islam is is the simplicity
of it
you know what i mean it doesn't matter
what color you are being show.com at the
end
you know i'm a big fan of your guys work
bismillah
assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
welcome to the dean show i'm eddie your
host subscribe if you haven't already
hit that notification bell
so you can get all of our up and coming
shows and my next guest is one of the
greatest players to ever play the sport
of rugby
he was only the second player to ever
represent new zealand rugby union after
first playing for the country in rugby
league
sonny bill williams was also inducted
into the rugby pass hall of fame in 2021
and is one of the only 21 players to
have won the rugby world cup twice
throughout his long and illustrious
career sonny bill williams has won
almost every trophy on offer in the
sport
but there is something greater that he
loves more than any of these things
and that's what we're going to be
talking about here on the d show with my
next special guest
sonny bill williams i might convert to
islam right now
[Music]
mercy and blessings of the creator that
heavens and earth be upon you so nice to
have you with us al hamdulillah
we made it
yes we made it firstly straight off the
bet on very sorry
um it been a couple of no shows
but um i've been extremely busy lately
and uh
humbly we're here
good to have you here my brother so
there was it did we hit that
introduction right
yeah over the top by the over the top
but uh i love what you said at the end
something that is
more important than anything and it's
allah's blessing and uh his blessing one
of my eldest daughters
[Music]
so it was early morning here in
australia habibi so the kids will be
coming waking up and uh getting ready
for school but yeah humbly allah's
blessings this that's what i try to
strive for my brother
tell us uh before we get into what you
love the most for just for help us
understand for us ignorant folks what's
the difference between american football
and rugby
um
both very
very physical violent games at times
but very skillful games at the same time
as well
and uh i think the big difference is we
play the game that you guys play without
pads without headgears without shoulder
pads without uh thigh pads so
some would say we're
we're the crazy version of the nfl
that's like the mma version of football
yes probably you could say that yeah
but uh there's a lot of i'm i'm a
polynesian my father is of samoan
heritage
so
uh you would go you would see a lot of
um my people playing in the nfl because
we're naturally others blessed our
people with being with physical gifts
you know we're naturally big strong
um
athletic uh people
absolutely subhanallah so that's like
you know we see the football here
american football and you got the
helmets the padding so just take all
that off and that's rugby and that's
pretty much
yes there's a few other subtleties to
the game but yeah you could say that
brother subhanallah so let's get into uh
this
quote from you it was really powerful i
actually also shared it some time ago
and
let's see what comes to your mind i want
you to react to
something you wrote yourself
and it was it went like this i chased
girls i drank alcohol spent lavishly and
thought i was someone that i wasn't
what did it give me hollowness emptiness
in my heart but i found allah god
almighty and i found islam submission to
god
sonny bill williams when you hear me
reading that what comes to your mind
the deenshow.com at the end
you know i'm a big fan of your guy's
work firstly sorry for not saying stay
sane at the outset but i'm a big fan of
you guys
and protect you and your loved ones
myself yeah gave me gives me shiver
shivers in my spine because
um
you know that was my life
uh i didn't
you know i
i strove so hard from a i guess sporting
perspective to make something of myself
in the sporting world because
you know growing up i grew up in a house
we call it housing commission household
here so um
the you know i wouldn't say the projects
but
uh
you get subsidised by the government and
my mom and dad both work low-income jobs
um our house for example we had no
wallpaper on the walls
mom and dad slept in the lounge room
just so we could have a a bedroom for
ourselves
me and my siblings
but
through that struggle um
it gave me that perseverance and and a
real simple outlook in life that if i
can and you know
in that space i didn't have uncles or
aunties or anyone in a
in a high income job and uh you know
living their life so i didn't have i
couldn't look at my uncle and say oh my
father would say i want to strive to be
like that i want to get i want to get
that job because it's going to give us a
good income or whatnot you know
um a lot of my uncles were in gangs
growing up
so i didn't really have that have that
person of prevalence or or in a position
of influence to strive to be
um
but humbly i went to school and i was i
was good at sport i was an athletic
person very athletic person i was good
at this game called rugby league rugby
union
um
the american viewers wouldn't be
uh aware of that game but it's like nfl
without the pad so i was really good at
that hamdulian
um i put all my effort into that because
i saw on tv
players playing on tv that look like me
so i connected with that straight away
and i thought my simplistic outlook in
my naive outlook was if i can play on tv
then i'll be able to then i'll be able
to buy mom a house with wallpaper and
that's that and that drove me that that
simplistic message
drove me to the heights that i reached
in this in the sporting field at such a
young age and with that came
money came
attention from the opposite sex but
although i was from a physical point of
view very strong
ready to take on the world
mentally
i was
i didn't have anything i was very
insecure i was i wasn't um equipped to
deal with the strip the the those
heights and what came with with uh fame
habibi so i really struggled in that
sense and that's why i made that
statement i was at a time where
from the outside looking in
um
i was the picture of success in the
western world we call it you know you've
got
fame and wealth and
um i was able to buy mom that house
wallpaper i had a flash car
i had had a lot of attention from the
opposite sex but i didn't know how to
i guess um
i wasn't confident in myself as a man
you know
and um i was just a follower brother i
was just to follow what follow because
these guys that i looked up to
uh on tv i was all of a sudden in the
same dressing room with them you know
the thing to do was train hard party
hard
you know and it's what i done and it led
me
down a
bad path where i where i ended up in a
space where i didn't know what mental
health was back then you know but when
looking back now i was i wasn't
almost close to depression uh
and because my will consisted of
okay i felt like i was a good person but
it consisted of
just
me what's in it for me you know how do i
move about this world for me what am i
going to get out of this why am i
feeling like this why do i have a nice
car and the opposite
sex is attention then and
i'm living in a nice house but why am i
so sad
you know and humbly i i stumbled upon
islam
and and humble
humble it taught me that
um
when you live for something greater than
oneself you know and giving you receive
so then giving your time whether it be
through charity or you know
alhamdulillah
i could sit here and talk about islam
all day for for the benefits that it's
given me it's given me a structure you
know it's given me
um boundaries
uh it's given me
um
a different such a beautiful outlook in
life for bibi where you know i know
where my bases for example over the
weekend
has blessed me with a job where i'm
talking about the game that i love
growing up a commentary called a comedy
gig but i was able to take my family
with me up queensland
uh
so you know a few days on the go
um
but i know that i guess spiritually
islamically um i'm still doing my
prayers and whatnot but i'm i'm not on
the on the pulse
so i know where my base is so this
morning humbly get up you go for me my
bases
i know i'm doing well i know i'm on the
path when i'm gone fajr and ishak
you know so you start that day off like
right and that's one of the beauties of
islam is giving me a structure that
of being
able to put my whole heart and soul into
and it's given me given me back tenfold
you know the hadith you take that step
towards allah it takes ten steps two
steps back towards you i really feel
that
subhanallah this is deep you know what
you were saying so
you talk about the
getting
your mother what you wanted the
pa
the house with the wallpaper
you know you have these good goals these
dreams but then you get hit with you
know the things that come with success
and then you know these are the kind of
things that people
they strive and they think that okay if
i get this that's it i'm gonna be happy
now you achieve all that you got the
money and all the other things that
uh men like and
what happens there's still a void there
huh it's still not filled until finally
you talk about another quote when i
found this islam it helped in changing
wildness in my life into positivity
it's
you know i feel like
and i feel like that's why i'm outspoken
in some ways you know my
the beauty of islam is the simplicity of
it
you know what i mean it doesn't matter
what color you are
you know the prophet peace be upon him
um
you know his last talks at uma
where he talks about non-arab uh doesn't
matter what you know non-arab or arab or
you know for me that hits home it hits
the heart and
um my wildness is allowed i guess that
wildness or that
you know that
that streak of i've been able to
turn that
into positivity where i walk that path
as much as i can without
uh
without fear because i feel i'll
especially
i fear the creator not creation and now
when i'm on that buzz
as you would know brother you know you
know that
um whatever happens is it comes from
allah you know you're not fearful when
um being able to speak up for injustice
uh as we see it as i see it sorry
but then also understanding
having that humbleness and understanding
that i will make mistakes too that i do
make mistakes and i will continue to
make mistakes but
as long as i'm seeking others
forgiveness i'm okay you know so
um there's there's been times when i
where i've come out and i've said said
things thinking that it was the right
thing to do but then i've understood
that that i was wrong you know and i'll
come out and apologize but at the same
time i'll always stand up for what i
think is right and
you know sometimes now we're in a place
in society where just just just being a
good person you know
sometimes if i'm
sometimes if i'm out in public in
you know you see an old lady carrying
bags you go up and say oh look would you
like me to carry it to your car
they almost look at you like you're
crazy like you know
but you're just trying to be a good
person you're struggling with blessings
you know
sometimes i i feel like we're looked at
like um
outrageous but i always feel like you
know
islam's taught me so much about life and
and everything starts in the heart
everything starts in the heart and
for me you know when i see a person that
i think oh he might be a muslim or you
know he might not be you know i just put
the i just have that wildness about me
i'm like salaam alaikum brother and they
look at me firstly and they're like
um you don't look like a muslim
there was another quote you talk about i
i'm sorry
there was a there was another quote uh
from you and there's so many beautiful
ones that you say i find peace and
happiness in doing my prayer and then
just
you know looking around us i try to
connect with let's say people of
influence who are out there
and you probably interact with a lot of
different celebrities one whose life is
just broadcasted now it's almost become
like a circus you know and you can't
help but feel sorry
you know
uh for certain individuals and you want
guidance for them you know you you want
the best for humanity right and that's
real love
so if you were to hang out now with
somebody whose life is just he talks
about openly about you know doing drugs
and testified a couple days ago that you
had done just about every kind of drug
there was by age
13 or 14 right 15 15. and you've
um
you've found that drugs are the only way
to numb your pain
right
they've always been
a medicine from a yes a numbing agent
and you said yesterday that in fact i i
think you said you take drugs to numb
the demons right
i don't know that i said to numb the
demons but i
have well
if i did say demons drinking
and and you would sometimes drink
whiskey in the mornings too right
during this time period um
i i
i you know i mean
isn't happy hour anytime
and that cocaine that those white lines
those are coca that's cocaine right
i would assume yeah and that's that's
your cocaine that you kept in that box
that says property of jd with the skull
and crossbones isn't it well the
beautiful composition of the photograph
would suggest that certainly and he's
kind he's going through so much now mr
johnny depp right
is that the kind of like when we look
back at your life you know what you were
you know going through that wildness and
do you think now if he just
did what you were doing like connecting
it with the prayer just putting your
head down on the ground you know you
know beseeching hell from the crater
that turns into earth you know you think
this would help you know if you can get
some of what you got now you know that
priceless gift that money can't buy but
you can get it for free
what would you say to someone if you're
hanging out with someone like johnny
depp and he's going to you see what he's
going through right now i was a mess i
was a wreck i was
shaking and
i just didn't understand why
and then i
looked down and
realized that the
the
the tip of my finger
had been
severed
and
i was
looking directly at
my bones
his cigarette
and and um
this is after the finger had
gone away
um
and she stubbed it out in my in in my
face and um on my cheek didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched don't tell me
what it feels like to be punched you
know even a lot of fights been around a
long time i don't know
you didn't get punched you got hit i'm
sorry i hit you like this but i did not
punch you i did not deck you i was
hitting you i don't know what the
promotion of my actual
hand was but you're fine i did not hurt
you i did not punch you i was hitting
you johnny physical fights
i did start a physical fight you did so
yes you did so you did the right thing
the big thing the you know what you are
admirable
well you know it's funny because
what led me to islam
besides meeting you know the
influential of the few influential
people in my in my life that helped me
learn
and step into um
to islam was
you know trying to help myself
i read many many self-help books you
know read so many
um
but
you know some of tony robbins
oh everything everything everything i've
read about 30 books i'd say when i was
going through my struggles but then when
i found islam i was like
subhanallah like this
caters for all of those books in one you
know
so for me i would say
in terms of the struggles that we have
in the dunya the kryptonite
is the quran and the hadith of the
prophet peace be upon him you know
whether it is you know like for example
sallallahu when you talk about sallah
you know i'm a bit of a deep thinker so
when i think about sallah i think about
five times and i put it in the context
of the self-help book because you know
not everyone for us when we're talking
it's easy because alhamdulillah you know
our point of reference is what allah and
the guidance that we have but when
you're talking to a non-believer or
someone that doesn't know islam
i always try and put it into that
context where i was when i was a little
bit lost or searching for something
because subhanallah how we've been
created we all want to belong we all
search for something you know they say
oh midlife crisis or whatever it is you
come to a point everyone comes to a
point where they're like what is this
world what is this dunya the only thing
in this life is certain is death
so why am i actually here you know
but just that point sallallahu
five times a day i would say five times
a day i strive to pray with my heart not
just my limbs and when you're doing that
when you're in the most vulnerable
position you can be hit in sajud it's
beautiful you know
um
in that position
naturally
and and you you you're doing it with the
sincerity in your heart naturally you're
grateful for whatever you have
you know
it might be just that little date that
you get to have
during during ramadan in a glass of
water so that little they taste like the
the the best food you've ever had as you
know bro you know so like for me
being in sahaja yog
or making salah with my heart i'm
grateful i'm grateful you know for
everything i'm you know
i'm grateful for the wealth allah has
given me you know because it's allowed
me to help my close ones it's allowed me
to live a life that and affect people in
the way that i would love to affect
people it's a
i think humbly for the for for the
blessings of my children you know that
um to be
to be a uh anyone can be a anyone you
know a lot of people can be parents
but
it takes time and effort and persistence
to be a great parent or a good parent
you know so
you know just things like that like i
sit there in and those are the things
that you think of or that i when i was
reading about reading the self out books
was you know you should
implement a bit of um
you know
contemplate during the day or think
about things that show you the gratitude
aspect of life we tick all of those
boxes we took a lot of these things when
we pray for and we do it five times a
day
you know um
so that's the things i would probably
say to johnny depp is uh
you know
keep an open mind
and just have a read you know just have
a read just have a read it reminded me
of myself getting home at two three in
the morning and the infomercials will
come on and when you started talking
about self-help books i remember tony
robbins
and i was in that same state you know
i'm just searching searching and then i
went and i bought back then it was like
the
it was the the
the dv cd cd set dvd set that i bought
hold uh 30 volumes and that and he's got
a lot of good stuff in there but it's
nothing like what you're talking about
the iman in your heart today will be
your guiding light for tomorrow when you
have allah god the creator that has an
earth with you you don't need anyone
else
you know this is really deep like you
know when you when you have because
people turn towards everything else but
you're singling out you're saying you
know when you have the creator with you
it's kind of like what muhammad ali was
saying you know i don't need nobody i'm
not scared of nobody but the one that i
love the most the one i fear the most
god almighty and you're just reiterating
just the same thing you know what i mean
but it's powerful you know people
understand can you comment on this also
this uh what was going through your mind
when you made this uh this post well
you know a lot of the times i
will tweet random thoughts uh
you know just come from the masjid or
fajr orisha or
you know i just have a real like moment
of knock and i feel like i've got that
moment of north that light in the heart
and i'm like
i also feel like
i feel like i'm a layman you know i'm a
real simplistic guy and and those are
the messages that hit my heart or when
i'm thinking i'm like you know what
that's actually a mad point or
um you know and
the beauty of social media you know
there's a lot of cons to social media
but there's other pros too when used in
the right way
and i just put the vulnerability head on
and i'm like this is how i feel and
uh
you know i feel like
when i'm in the streets even you know
non-muslims come up to me and they're
like man like your messages are powerful
like and i'm like well those messages
are just simplicity simple ones from
coming from a simple sportsman
you know are you i connected with
coaches salaam alaikum
connected i connected with coaches that
would have the simplistic messages you
know like i played a simple game
sometimes people like to over complicate
this the game where in life we live a
simple life
it can be a simple life sorry
but we over complicated wanting this and
that that this and that and i want this
and i need this and i need that but now
when you bring it back down
and and
you just simplify it
as long as i got that
as long as i'm striving for
the creator's respect i'll get the
creations respect no doubt
is that what when you talk about
simplicity is that what finally had you
accept islam when you looked into it
that the simple message of worshiping
one and only one god and being morally
upright simple message simple to
understand
yes 100 you know i grew up i didn't grow
up in a religious household but i
grew up with a lot of uh with all my
close friends
were pretty much polynesians you know
um big religious households
so you know i believed in god
um the beauty in in the key of islam was
one god allah you know
that's the point of reference like for
me there's there's no and the other
thing i love about islam is that there's
no great areas you know i love the fact
that there should be sepa separation you
know we go to a wedding islamic wedding
in the men in one room and a woman in
one room
you know i love that because i come from
a place where it's free for you know you
i've i've been in situations where you
know you hang out with other couples and
i've seen
you know some of
some mates end up with other mates
partners and whatnot so i've seen the
struggles of that but so for me
i look i look at it like that it's
it's a beautiful thing when i'm getting
ready with my wife i'm like my love do i
look good she's like yeah you look good
she's like
you look beautiful
like all right then go to the wedding
and i know that i'm just looking good
for her and then i go and hang out with
the boys you know what i mean and she
goes hangs out with the ladies so you
know um
i look at it from i'm a simple man and i
understand
the struggles i've understand i
understand the beautiful beautiful and
the wisdom behind that because i've seen
the struggles if that makes sense well
that makes talk i mean and i'm just
really uh i'm elated that someone
like yourself who would come out and you
know to mention that because it's
something that goes what we say the
fitra and the rita and you know this is
their protective jealousy this goes with
the the ma the nature the the natural
way and a lot of times we we just get it
gets it gets convoluted and it gets
confusing because social pressure and
things are acceptable in society and
that but you know a lot of the even a
lot of conservative christians and a lot
of people who you know
who can identify with this and just
people of god consciousness you know
what you're just saying but they don't
have you know a voice an avenue because
they've accepted everything else that
out there is normal
and now you're you're you know so many
people what you what you said they would
identify with this you know it's it's
very very deep
very deep i want to go into my my next
question here
uh it seems like tell us about we heard
that your your your life is at stake
you're on some kind of hit list
uh sunny williams out of australia so
there's a lot of people
on the hit list by some guy uh jake paul
brother logan paul
what's going on there
you got that
on you
well um
i wouldn't say a hit
it's kind of funny me being in the fight
game because i feel like i'm such a
loving guy you know um
and i don't really have animosity to
anyone and and i just love people doing
well and when it comes to jake paul i
love what he's what he's done as a
fighter because he's come from he was a
youtuber
but with with persistence with work
ethic
um and with time
you know he's worked himself up to be
pretty pretty good pretty decent so i
respect i respect the grind because i'm
exactly the same my grind the same way
you know
uh but yeah
for me i understand too that this in
this sport it's a business and when i
hear him mentioning him or his people
and himself mentioning my name i
understand he's he's got the american
market and you know
and whatnot but i i think they wanted to
tap into the australasian market
and
my last fight i'm delayed my last fight
done really well with the pay-per-view
numbers and whatnot and and i and i i i
have a feeling that his people would
have got wind of that
so when they're speaking dollars and
cents of course they want to reach out
and cut and get into this market so i
just said you know um
if you want to come down here we play we
play sport we play uh rugby league the
nfl version with notepad so if you want
to come down here here it'll be a great
experience because i respect what you do
but uh it will be your first loss too
you know just a bit of tongue-in-cheek
yeah i actually did a video where i was
inviting his older brother logan paul
uh because he was talking a little bit
about religion and islam
their god yes
you know uh
in islam
allah is is the god and judaism jesus is
the god and uh
jesus is not god he never called people
to worship him as a god as a literal son
of god he called people to worship the
one god along without associates and he
also warned people of the hellfire and
he gave the glad tidings of paradise
eternal life in the next
paradise and so did all the other
messengers they came with that same
message not
contradictory messages
one coming and saying worship me the
other one coming worship the song the
other one won't come saying worship the
moon the other one saying worship money
no that's where you're confused
because i'm i'm confused another video
specific video inviting him you know to
islam
uh maybe we can we can go ahead uh if
you get to connect with him you can go
ahead and share some of this so we can
get this message to his little brother
jake palm invite him also to the dean to
islam huh of course
you know it's outrageous to think
sometimes when you sit there you think
that oh you know islam jake paul
islam
his brother but you know i look at it
like for myself allah
allah wills who he wants
you know
and i would never i've thought that
growing up that i would be be a muslim
alhamdulillah i'm here now
could you talk about you were searching
for something becoming a muslim
was the best thing that could have ever
happened to you
and uh you even your best friend was
your teammate what are your teammate was
it alpha how do you uh
you offered
[Music]
yes and he's quoting here this is one of
the
uh passages from the verbatim word of
god almighty allah the quran this is in
english the meaning verily with every
hardship comes ease had the most amazing
experience visiting my muslim brothers
in hospital on the weekend and inspired
and draw so this is one of your
teammates and he actually
he uh would you ever think that he
actually would also accept islam huh
yeah subhanallah subhanallah and that
wasn't
you know um
i was actually
salaam alaikum
not just him but your mother your mother
also did right you had a lot of your
friend your mother also accepted islam
is that right
my mom accepted um islam my brothers
accepted islam
but a lot of it um has just probably
been through
the way that they've seen it affect
islam affect my life and change my life
in such a positive way
um
excuse me bro with that we're done at
the at the not the wrong time but it's
in the morning rush you know
we're just on the plane once and i had a
uh
i had a um what was it what becomes of
the broke of how to heal a broken heart
i think
yasmine forgot the last name but it was
a beautiful book it's a beautiful book
anyway i was sitting there reading it
and you said this he just happened to be
sitting next to me
and um
when we started getting talking it was
like we're flying it was with your
blacks so we flew from new zealand i
think we're flying the uk so it was a
long long long long flight
and um we're talking about it and then i
ended up he's asking about the book you
know i just gave him the book you know
what it's like brother if anyone chose a
little bit of interest in
what we're about you're so you know you
want because you want the feeling that
you have for anyone else yes
and then subhanallah
usually
with with with rugby
and the all blacks
the
backs always room with the backs and the
forwards room with the floors but on
this trip they said oh we're going to
mix it up
the backs are going to be rooming with
the floors this trip
and who did i who who was my roommate
or footsong fussy
and you know we got on well uh oh he was
always a lovely guy
but we never really connected in a deep
way and and so he was from the opposite
team
now we're on the same team same team but
you never connected before
we were on this we're not actually we
were on the same team too but we never
really like it was like hey brother hey
bro you know how's the family here
everyone's good you know
like you know but it wasn't we'd never
sit down or go for a feed or hang out or
you know what i mean
and then we end up rooming together that
week and uh
subhanallah
you know he's a brother now and
he's a really good guy he's still
playing for the all blacks so
um whenever you can and you're in the
sporting world in the sporting context
um
for brother or for donald farsi to do
well on the footy fields because he's
doing really well and and representing
us on that and on that highest level
well i want to i want to thank you very
much uh front end time and sharing some
of the highlights and
uh of your life and god willing
inshallah it's gonna be a benefit to so
many so many people out there it can be
from the johnny depp's to the johnnies
to the mikeys to you know the logan
paul's whatever because on the outside
like you you were you were looking all
good right but from the inside your
heart was searching for something more
and you found it now and you're sharing
that it's illuminating from you and it's
something you can see you love talking
about and that's the beautiful thing i
want to commend you because there's a
lot of people and there's different
levels obviously you know and
everybody's at a different phase in
their life but you know you could be the
strongest toughest person but sometimes
people you know they're scared to go
ahead and you know to talk about certain
things and you know you just
you know just to be like muhammad ali
out there he loved talking about islam
he loved talking about his creator
inshallah you can continue that legacy
and use what god almighty allah gave you
to go ahead and you know
make a good positive difference out
there in the world inshallah
brother and thank you for having me on
your show it's been a long time coming
i'm a big supporter of you guys i love
you with yours and other watches thank
you my brother so much may allah bless
you
and that was our special guest sonny
bill williams and i want to thank you
sonny for being with us here on the dean
show so you could be the johnny depps of
the world you can be the logan pauls and
jake paul doesn't matter you can have
all the money
and the fame but at the end of the day
just like sonny bill williams he had all
those things but he was empty inside and
nothing will fill that void except
what the the way of life because truly
in the remembrance of your creator of
the created heavens and earth god
almighty allah do hearts find
satisfaction do they find rest do they
find peace they find contentment
so you tried all the coke and the dope
and the drinks and the drugs and all
that other stuff you've had all the
fancy cars you tried everything you put
it here you put it there you put it
everywhere
why don't you try
brave be courageous beseeching the one
who created you saying the all loving
the most kind the most the one who
created me go to created creation guide
me guide me guide me
very simple and that's what i like sonny
bill williams
you know what he talked about
islam it was simple to understand
worship the creator not the creation be
morally upright simple not convoluted
not complicated and if you can start
with that homework and then i'd like to
give you a free gift
go to thedeenshow.com
and get your free copy of the quran and
we'll be here to help you along your way
we'll see you next time subscribe if you
haven't or if you haven't already
and continue to tune in to the dean show
thank you once again
until next time peace be with you
and if you like this episode of the dean
show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum